cancel me do whatever the heck you want
but i'm always going to state the truth
and the truth today is that black lives
matter exploited the death of george
floyd and made millions
of what they call the pain of black
people
[Music]
can you believe it i'm still here living
inside this tent for 100 days from
november 20th to february 28th bring to
you the issues and awareness that you
need to know about the violence on the
south side of chicago but also to raise
as much money as we possibly can to
build a community center on this
much-needed block called o-block it's
called o-block because it's named after
a young man named od perry who was shot
and killed the gangs took the o in his
name and started calling it o block we
decided we're going to keep the o but
we're going to change it to opportunity
block i want to thank fox network for
giving me the opportunity every day to
bring you the rooftop revelations where
i share with you my thoughts viewpoints
and opinions
counsel me do whatever the heck you want
but i'm always going to state the truth
and the truth today is that black lives
matter exploited the death of george
floyd and made millions
of what they call the pain of black
people
this is simply reprehensible
i just read the washington examiner
report that said
millions are unaccounted for
after all the three original black lives
matter leaders have currently resigned
the amount given was 60 million
60 million i believe is probably far
more
if there's no accountability within
black lives matter board and if there's
such shadiness within the organization
over all the money then you can bet
there's even more money that's being hit
what angers me is how disrespectful and
selfish black lives matter is
they claim to care about
black people more than anyone
but where are they
i don't see them around here
believe me we got plenty of work around
here to do
and we would have no problem putting
them to work
if black lives matter really matters
then why aren't they here
do they not see the same weekly
headlines that we all see
what makes me especially mad is that we
have had black lives
and blacks like these who milk black
pain for money ever since we came out of
slavery
we called them trickster figures
when booker t washington wrote these
words over 100 years ago
he was describing to me
b.l.m today
he says
and i quote there is a class of colored
people who make a business of keeping
the troubles the wrongs and the
hardships of the negro race before the
public
having learned that they are able to
make a living out of their troubles they
have grown into the settled habit of
advertising their wrongs partly because
they want sympathy and partly because it
pays
some of these people
do not want the negro to lose his
grievances because they do not want to
lose their jobs let me repeat
some of these people do not want the
negro to lose his grievances
let that sink in folks
you know who they're talking about the
folks right here
right here in these streets they want
these folks to stay beaten down and
downtrodden they want to hold up the
very people whose lives
have been
are that they're trying to improve for
for the last 20 years
and they want to hold these people up to
americans and say see how bad you treat
us
give us money
that's what black lives matter does
while buying houses for themselves all
over america and headquarters in canada
the article even said that black lives
matter folks dropped nearly 26 000
for meetings at a malibu resort dang it
hurts me even to say the word malibu as
much as i'm freezing out here in chicago
trying to raise awareness for the real
problems that my people are going
through
it shames me
to see brothers and sisters
exploiting our pain it truly does
let that be a dark mark on the heads of
blm the jig is up
meanwhile the work continues here every
day we continue to mentor we continue to
counsel we continue to offer pathways to
opportunities and we will never stop
doing what we are called to do because
that's what we have to do if we're ever
going to change the lives of people on
the south side of chicago and inner
cities across the world we must continue
to work
and not
follow the example of blm
well as i always say these are just my
thoughts viewpoints and opinions thank
you for tuning in to rooftop revelations
god bless you god bless america and
until tomorrow
peace
you